When I went to the preview screening of Happy
Death Day, director Christopher Landon offered
some insight about the sequel in a Q&A.
If you want to hear about that, stick around
to the end of this video.
Happy Death Day was one of the better surprises
of 2017.
"Surprise?"
No pun intended.
What appeared to be a generic slasher actually
ended being a pretty decent mystery that kind
of threw me for a loop.
Pun only slightly intended.
It was definitely more than just Groundhog
Day gone horror, but with the announcement
of the sequel, Happy Death Day 2U, the question
becomes, can they do it again?
Let's start by looking at what we know about
the new film.
The first movie took place on Theresa's birthday,
and she had to keep reliving it until she
solved the puzzle.
The addition of the "2U" to the title could
be a continuation of the song that goes 'Happy
Birthday To You', but I think this sequel
will have Tree reliving a different day on
the calendar.
Happy Death Day 2U is scheduled to release
on Valentine's Day 2019.
The '2U' in the title is styled like the text
on one of those candy hearts with messages
on them that you see around Valentine's Day.
So I think the new movie takes place 4 months
later on February 14th, which is actually
horrifying, I can't think of a worse day to
be trapped in; to have to relive over and
over.
If you saw my initial Things You Missed on
the Happy Death Day trailer last year, you'll
know that I was disappointed that the song
"Happy Death Day", by Alien Ant Farm did not
end up in the movie.
Well this time, they literally have no excuse
not to.
The lyrics literally have the title of the
movie.
Roll it.
"With the girl I'd love to kill...
Happy Death Day to you baby."
I'm not talking about just having a licensed
song in the trailer, but not the movie, we're
not falling for that again.
"Hey, it's my birthday.
Now you gotta pick up the phone."
Come on Jason Blum.
I know you're watching this.
I know you're here to false copyright claim
this video so you can squeeze those precious
pennies out of me before I file a dispute,
but while you're here, let's make this song
thing happen.
Or at the very least, get Dethklok in there.
"Die.
Die.
Death.
Day.
Birth.
Death.
Day."
But yeah, as I mentioned earlier, the director
of Happy Death Day, Christopher Landon, did
a Q&A at a preview screening I attended last
year, where he was asked about a possible
sequel.
Keep in mind this was before Happy Death Day
had come out and pulled $120M at the box office,
and he said he already had a sequel in mind.
That alone should give you some hope that
it'll be decent, because that shows me that
the sequel is story motivated and not just
money motivated.
He also deflected questions about the cause
of the time-loop and hinted that we could
get more info about why it takes place in
a sequel.
One of the things that made the first movie
work was that it didn't try to over explain
things, and instead focused on character relationships
and growth.
If the sequel can replicate that while introducing
more information about the setting and concept,
I think we'll have a "repeat" success.
Pun intended.
If you haven't seen my Things You Missed on
Happy Death Day, be sure to click the video
on the left to watch that.
If you'd like to see me do a Things You Missed
on Happy Death 2U, then leave a like on this
video to let me know.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that deathbell for
notifications and I'll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.